les promoteurs de l'intégration
européenne mais du fédéralisme européen
ils veulent absolument imposer leur
modèle deux projets européens qui est
basé sur des paradigmes je dirais ancré
dans le siècle dernier obsolètes par
rapport au monde multipolaire
aujourd'hui et d'où d'ailleurs la
désaffection des peuples par rapport à
ce projet européen et je pense qu'il est
important d'avoir une alliance entre
états européens dans ce monde
multipolaire mais une europe
géopolitique et c'est les débats qui
sont organisées au niveau institutionnel
contre cette conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe ne va pas changer la crise
fondamentale la crise des fondements de
l'europe parce que les européistes vont
essayer de toujours de promouvoir en
fait non pas l'europe civilisationnel
mais une une europe des normes qu'on
appelle l'europe des valeurs mais ce
sont des normes de gouvernement en fait